Managing emotions, yours and your
audiences, is hard enough, but it's even
harder when you're under pressure to
respond. I'm Matt Abrahams. I teach
strategic communication at Stamford
Graduate School of Business. Welcome to
this quick thinks episode of Think Fast,
Talk Smart, the podcast. Today's episode
is a special one. We're taking you
inside a recent live learning community,
Ask Matt Anything that I hosted. Take a
listen as I answer realworld
communication challenges. We discuss how
to manage cognitive load when you're
under stress, the power of breath work
for regulating your nervous system,
[music]
and practical strategies for running
meetings that stay on track and keep
people engaged. Enjoy this quick thinks
episode packed with engagement,
education, and actionable advice you can
start using today. Well, hello
everybody. I am thrilled to be here with
you and hopefully there are a few things
I can share with you that might be of
use. So I'm open to any questions you
have about communication that you think
I might have some insight on. Would
anybody like to start? Natalie, please.
>> Yeah. So English is not my first
language. I think by now I speak pretty
decent English, but my original mother
language is Portuguese. And I moved to
US recently. And one thing I'm
struggling with sometimes when I have
high stakes conversations, I feel the
quality of my English decreases a lot.
So I wonder if you have any advice on
how to modulate that and make my English
sound the same quality that it has, not
worse.
>> Thank you for the question. I think the
experience is very common. And while I
think it's accentuated for people who
are speaking in a language that's not
their native language, I think this is
true of everybody, all people, that when
we feel stress or emotion, like we're
really passionate about something that
we might not articulate our thoughts as
well. And this really has to do with
cognitive load. Your brain is like a
computer. You know, when you have your
laptop or your phone and you have lots
of windows or apps open, each one of
those is performing less well because
the others are open. And the same thing
happens with our brains that when I get
nervous, when I get excited, highly
emotional, when I'm worried that I might
not be using the right words, that in
and of itself, those emotions take some
of our precious cognitive load bandwidth
that we have and it makes it harder for
us to accomplish what we're trying to
accomplish. So first and best way to
handle this is to reduce the cognitive
load that the emotion has. So if you are
somebody who gets nervous when you're
advocating in a highstakes situation,
managing the anxiety will reduce the
cognitive load. If you're somebody who's
really passionate and excited about
something, taking the opportunity to
recognize that emotion and put it to the
side perhaps so in the moment you can be
focused. That can help. So, it's really
about emotional regulation to help. Now,
that sounds easy, like, oh, okay, great.
I'll just manage my emotions. It's very
hard to do, right? Especially if it's
based on anxiety or concern over grammar
and vocabulary, etc. So, it takes
practice. It takes practice and
simulation is important. So one way to
practice is to simulate these highstakes
situations. If you can stress test
yourself in situations that are similar,
then you are better prepared. So
managing the anxiety and you know I do a
lot of work on anxiety management, lots
of podcast episodes on it, lots of
writing about it. And then also finding
situations where you put yourself in
that stressful situation so you become
more accustomed to it. That will free up
more cognitive bandwidth. So, I hope
there's something there, Natalie, that
sounds useful to you, but it's really
about the cognitive load and anything we
can do to reduce the cognitive load of
the circumstance will help you
articulate your thoughts better. Thank
you, Aran. I'm curious if you have a
question.
>> I do have a question, Matt. We live in
an uncertain economic times. We lot of
companies are restructuring. So as
leaders we are in a very highstake
situation where we have to talk to our
teams or followers and often times what
we see is that there's a lot of anxiety
and nervousness in the audience when
you're talking to let's say 10 people or
50 people or 500 people there is that
general sense of anxiety and it gets
compounded especially when you are on a
zoom or something. My question is how do
one approach something like this and put
the anxiety and the level of angst that
people have at rest and communicate what
needs to be communicated in a thoughtful
way. It is true that times are turbulent
and things are changing and that can be
very unsettling for people and often
that brings anxiety and concern and as
leaders as people in positions of power
it's important to recognize that and
it's important to recognize that the
messages you have are important to get
across but if people are in a state of
fear and concern they might not hear it
or hear it the way you want. So, it's
important for you to be empathetic and
to recognize that and the work you do in
advance to expect it. So, before I ever
walk into that room, log into that Zoom,
I'm thinking about my audience. You've
heard me say that lots and lots before
and on the podcast, it's the number one
bit of advice people share is know your
audience. And part of that is
understanding their likely emotional
state. And you can figure that out by
just your own empathy. How would I feel
if I'm in that position? By asking
people. There are lots of ways to
determine that. So, you shouldn't be
surprised by it if you do your
preparation right. Now, I know in
spontaneous situations where things just
happen, you might have to deal with it
in the moment. I believe the best way to
handle it is to recognize it and to
start by naming it. You know, if people
are sitting there in fear and concern,
it's important to say there are a lot of
things changing and they're changing in
ways that are unpredictable and
ambiguous. And today I want to share how
we're addressing it and some of the
things that we're doing. And I want to
fully appreciate and honor the fact that
some of us, myself included, can be very
concerned at this time. So naming it can
be very helpful to recognize and making
yourself available to have conversations
about it. So you might say, "And after
I'm done speaking or in the next week or
so, I very much would like to hear from
all of you to better understand your
concerns." So it's acknowledging it and
then it's providing an avenue to have a
discussion about it. I think that's
first and foremost most important. Doing
the homework in advance to understand
it. Maybe setting expectations. I am a
huge fan of setting expectations in
advance of communication if possible. A
meeting invite, a conversation with
people before the presentation or
meeting to help people understand what
you're doing and the fact that you
recognize that this is fraught with
concern. And then at the end check in
with people. at the end come back and
say, "I hope the things that I've shared
give some insight in input that is
helpful as you experience these things
uh as concerning." So, making sure to
really acknowledge that even though
you've just said something that
hopefully helps with some of that
anxiety, that it still might exist in
what you're doing to follow up with it.
This is going to help you and your
audience to connect and to really digest
the information. It is hard for many
people to live in ambiguity and anxiety
and to help them understand that it's
normal and natural and that you
appreciate it I think gets you a long
way towards your goal. Thank you for
that question. Nesser, you have a
question.
>> Good morning, Matt. So, I'm sure like
many I'm in a position to lead a lot of
meetings. Sometimes fun meetings,
sometimes introductory project meetings,
sometimes project updates are not going
so well. And for the most part, I think
we all do a reasonably good job. But
I've always struggled with
repetitiveness of starting meetings. You
know, you come in there with the basics
of thank you for joining. I'm glad to be
here, etc., etc. But I'd love to hear
from a communication sciences
perspective, your view, and maybe even
examples of what you use to engage
audiences. If I lead a team meeting or
even board meetings, what are some great
ice breakers to really get people fully
tuned in? And then as the meeting
progresses, we have a tendency to
deviate from what the core subject or
the topic we were presenting, right? So
what's your advice for getting that
meeting back on track and staying
focused without alienating people?
>> So two really important questions there
and questions that I think a lot of us
struggle with in meetings and that is
how do we engage and get things moving
forward in a way that's not repetitive
or actually working against ourselves
and then how do we stay on track. I
believe that there's a lot of work that
can be done in advance of the meeting
actually taking place. I think the most
underutilized expectation setting tool
is the calendar invite. And I think
there's a lot you can do in the calendar
invite to set people's expectations and
to engage them before you start. Just
thinking about how you title the
meeting. What is it called? Many of us
just do blah blah blah meeting. That's
not very engaging or interesting. Is
there a way I can name the meeting that
encourages people to perhaps get excited
or focused on it? So maybe thinking
about the action or the main action that
you'll be doing in the meeting. So can
you put a verb, an action in the title
of your meeting, what I like to do is I
like to pose a question or a challenge
in all of my calendar invites and I
start our meetings with that challenge
or with that question. So when people
come to the meeting, they know that's
how we're starting. Most people don't
like coming to meetings and so we're
going to start this meeting by reviewing
the previous meeting you didn't like.
That makes no sense to me. So starting
with some kind of action, some kind of
question and engagement can be really
helpful. Using ice breakers is a great
way to start. There are lots of tools.
You know, if it's a recurring meeting
where people know each other, maybe a
simple check-in just to see where people
are emotionally or stresswise. You know,
people use a stoplight. Are you red,
green, yellow? Sometimes people use a
weather forecast. Are you cloudy? Are
you sunny? There are other icebreers if
you don't know groups well or people
well to get people to know each other,
get them interacting with each other.
One of my favorites that I use in all of
my classes is an activity where I ask
people to find things they have in
common and then share those things. It
gets people talking. It gets them
discussing. It's low stakes. So, how you
set expectations up front and how you
start really matters. I like starting
with engagement before I get to
repeating or recounting what happened
before. Now, in terms of how to stay on
track, part of what I include in my
meeting invites is an agenda. Agendas
are important. They are a structure for
the meeting and I make it very clear at
the beginning of the meetings that we
have an agenda. There's time allocated
to different aspects and if we need to
deviate from that, we all have to agree.
So, if I find that as I'm facilitating
the meeting, we have drift in some
direction. Maybe it's a great direction,
maybe it's a tangential direction. I
call it out. I say, "Just want to remind
everybody, we've got these items on the
agenda. Where are we going? Do we want
to allocate time to this or not?" So,
the meta awareness and calling that out
as a leader, I think, is really
important. Also, if you need to pull
people back just because somebody's
talking too much or they're starting to
go on a tangent, this is where
paraphrasing can be really helpful. Take
something of value the person has said,
name it, and then pull it back. So I
might say Nesser that point was really
important about delivery date and it
actually ties to the next item of the
agenda which is our implementation plan.
So I interrupt you name something
important that you've said and then
connect it to what's coming next. That's
a really useful way for me to keep the
meeting moving and then at the end of
the meeting it's really important to
come back and assess how the meeting
went. So take 30 seconds, a minute at
the end of the meeting and just debrief
the quality of the meeting. Not
rehashing the issues, but I might say,
"It was really helpful when Camille
paraphrased that point. It got us back
on track." Or when Natalie asked that
question when we were sort of
floundering, that really helped us. And
what I'm doing there is I'm rewarding
the positive behaviors that help the
meeting run well. And it's sending a
signal that I'm trying to make these
meetings run really well. And I need
your help. and I'm noticing what you're
doing when you do help me. I'd like to
take maybe one more question, please.
Ken.
>> Yeah. Actually, what happened after
Stanford is after returning back to
Oslo, the business situation was much
more challenging than I was expecting
and it was probably the most challenging
months in my professional career. So it
was really really tough situation until
the end of last year until I got a real
good overview on where we are, what are
the challenges, how to move forward and
communicated actually to a team and
wrote a thank you for your commitment
despite the difficult situation and so
on. But I also wanted to convey a clear
message actually that the entire team
needs to change. We need to adapt to the
new circumstances. we need to accelerate
maybe also processes the way of working
etc. It's not like only waiting for
management to fix it needs to be every
single one who needs to somehow adapt
and to do the change. So for me the key
point is I would like now to follow up
on this and to try to communicate in a
way that I can actually how to say catch
everyone still I I feel that some people
got it already but I don't want to do it
in a threatening way you know that
people are afraid and this anxiety etc
etc so I want to catch the people and
this is kind of the challenge for the
communication I have
>> right so thank you Ken I appreciate you
giving us context. So essentially, how
do I motivate change that is significant
in a way that doesn't invoke anxiety and
concern? And that's very hard. I have a
few thoughts. First, I really think you
should lean into the mission, vision,
values that you have in the
organization. In theory, everybody in
your firm, in your company believes in
and supports those mission, vision,
values. So if you can lean into them and
really share what you are advocating
for, the changes you are encouraging
people to take on, connect to and really
relate to the mission, vision, values
that you have. What we know from lots of
research in social science is if you can
tap into what currently motivates
people, they are much more likely to be
open to what it is you're saying because
you're showing what you're asking for is
consistent with what they've already
done. So is there a way to make that
message clear that the mission vision
values have not changed but the
activities we need to do in support of
them have to change. Second you have to
make the message salient and relevant to
the different people different roles
different levels of the organization
have different key areas that are
important to them. So you have to morph
the message you have to target the
message to be relevant to individuals.
People only act on things that they see
as relevant and important to them. So we
don't create one broadcast message and
send it to everybody. We have to tailor
that message. And sometimes we can just
ask people to help us do that. So you
can give a broadcast message and then
challenge everybody to think about the
implications that has for them and how
they can contribute. And you have to
have clear lines of connection between
what you're asking people to do and the
goal that you're trying to achieve.
People need to see that what they're
being asked to do connects to the
broader picture. So creating a
communication infrastructure around
these change messages becomes very
important. That means you have to think
about targeting the message differently
to different people. You have to have
different processes in place to get the
feedback and repeat the message. We have
to repeat messages over and over. And
you might need to even look at different
channels for delivering the message
depending on the people. You know the
class I teach is strategic
communication. We have to be very
strategic about the communication. It
takes a lot of work, but I like that
you're sensitive to how important
communication is. So, thank you there.
And I thank all of you for joining me
today and for the insightful questions.
It was a true thrill to be with you.
Thank you for joining us for another
episode of Think Fast Talks Smart the
podcast. To learn more about all of
these various skills, take a listen to
our back catalog. This episode was
produced by Katherine Reed, [music] Ryan
Campos, and me, Matt Abrahams. Our music
is from Floyd Wonder with [music]
special thanks to Podium Podcast
Company. Please find us on YouTube and
wherever you get your podcasts. Be sure
to subscribe and rate us. Also, follow
us on LinkedIn, Tik Tok, and Instagram.
And check out faster.io for deep dive
videos, English language learning
content, and our newsletter. Please
consider joining our ThinkFast Talks
Smart Learning community at faster.io.
io/arning. You'll find video lessons,
learning quests, discussion boards, an
AI coach, and book club opportunities.
Again, that's faster.io/arning
to become part of our thinkfast talks
smart learning community.